KAZ SATO: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for taking the time
for our session from siloed ML
to ML service mesh
using API management.
I'm Kaz Sato, developer
advocate from Google Cloud based
in Tokyo.
RAKESH TALANKI:
I'm Rakesh Talanki.
I'm Google Cloud
architect on Apigee team.
I'm in Atlanta, Georgia.
KAZ SATO: In this session,
we try to cover these topics.
First, I directly
discuss about how
you can build a scalable
machine learning
production system with
Google Cloud's AI platform.
Then I will discuss
about the second problem
that is called siloed ML
and how you can solve that
by using ML service mesh.
In the latter part
of this session,
Rakesh will discuss
about API management
and how it can help
building ML service mesh.
So let's start
discussing about how
you can build a scalable
machine learning system
with AI platform.
Now many data
scientists or companies
are trying to bring the PoC
system into a production
machine learning system.
But those PoC or prototypes can
be all covered by a single data
scientist, but for
production system,
you have to split
the responsibility
into the multiple roles.
For example, data
engineer can be
responsible for ingesting
the data from data warehouse
and apply some
pre-processing against that,
whereas data scientists
and ML engineers
can be responsible for
training the module,
design the machine learning
model, get the higher accuracy,
and to push the training
model into the system.
And then ops engineer
or ML engineer
can be responsible for designing
the scalable and continuous
training and prediction system.
We'll think about a scenario
where the data scientist
is visiting a cubicle
of the ops teams
to ask to bring the PoC
systems into production system.
What kind of the problems
the ops team have to solve?
There are many different gaps
between PoC and production.
For example, many
PoC notebooks can
be locally dependent or
dependent on a single person.
But with production
system, you have
to make everything
portable and shareable.
And you cannot rely on a single
notebook instance anymore.
You have to think
about build a cluster
of those multiple instances
with the scaling out or scaling
in functionalities
or load balancing
of the incoming
prediction requests.
And everything should
not be dependent
on the manual process.
Everything should
be reproducible
for the end-to-end machine
learning life cycle.
And lastly, you have to
think about monitoring
so that ops team can be
responsible for the continuous
monitoring and routing for
the continuous operation.
So though that the reason
why Google provides a product
called Cloud AI platform that
has two features, training
and prediction.
Those are managed services for
machine learning, training,
and prediction.
For example, if you are using
machine learning prediction
of Cloud AI platform,
then you don't
have to spend your time for
building a scalable prediction
infrastructure by yourself.
Instead, the managed
service can take
care of the adding
more instances
or removing the instances based
on the current workload you
are getting for the
prediction system.
And also, it can provide
a distributed GPU and TPU
training service.
So you can easily get the
distributed the GPU environment
without spending much time
on building a GPU cluster.
And also, the service can
provide the logging features
using the BigQuery
data warehouse.
So that makes much
easier for building
a continuous monitoring setup.
So by using Cloud
AI platform, you
can easily get those
benefits required
for the scalable
machine learning system.
That includes the scheduling
of the old instances,
lifecycle management of those
continuous instances, scaling
out and scaling in
functionalities, load balancing
and dispatching the workloads,
logging, monitoring,
troubleshooting, and security.
You don't have to build those
features from the scratch
by yourself.
Instead, those
features are already
available in AI platform.
But for the large
enterprises, that
is not the end of the story.
So for example, let's imagine
a scenario where you have just
finished building
a machine learning
pipeline for a single
service-like recommendation.
If it's a large
enterprise, then you
have to move onto another
project like ads optimization.
Then you have to build another
service, fraud detection,
demand forecasting, customer
support, research, and so on.
So without thinking about
sharing any intermediate result
or assets, you'd easily end
up with having multiple silos
of machine learning pipeline.
That is an anti-pattern
called siloed ML.
So for example, for building
a recommendation system,
maybe you are getting the
user profile or user vector
from user activities
or a product vector
from full product
description, tutoring a model
for recommendation service.
So the solution could
be building a machine
learning service mesh.
You could start with building
a monolith kind of this service
that has everything inside
it, but gradually you
can split your
responsibility into
the multiple microservices.
And eventually you'd have the
bunch of the microservices that
can be easily composed to
build a final machine learning
service for the
clients or consumers.
For example, in case of
the recommendation systems,
rather than building on the
monolith of the recommendation
systems, but you can
split those services
into the three microservices.
The ML service A can
predict a user vector
from these activities.
Service B can predict
a product vector
from product description.
Then you could have
another service, C,
that can those user
vector and product
vector to provide our
recommendation result so
that you can easily reuse
those internal assets like user
vectors and product vector
for the other purposes.
So this is your solution
called ML service mesh,
but the missing link here
is the API management.
And why is that?
Because if you are working
for a large enterprises,
you have to think
about how to share
those assets with the proper
business model and security
model.
You cannot just expose your
APIs without any of the tracking
and monitoring for that.
So missing link here
is the API management
for the ML service mesh.
So I direct you past
this screen to Rakesh.
He will be discussing
more about API management.
KAZ SATO: Thank you Kaz.
So let's continue with the
description where Kaz stopped.
So we have the ML pipelines.
You want to introduce them as
part of enterprise consumption.
So how do you go about?
You might have
internal consumers,
mostly for the ML pipelines.
It might be internal consumers.
But you might also have
the external consumption,
the third party, where
you don't have control.
So the idea here is how can
you take your pipelines,
or it can be other
services, and make
them easily consumable
by your consumers
without any friction ideally
in a self-service mode?
So this is where we're
going to talk about
on how to make it happen.
Most of the companies,
most of the enterprises
on this journey moving from
monoliths into microservices.
Maybe some companies are
halfway through to service
or [INAUDIBLE] architectures,
but still, the journey
is going on into
breaking down monoliths
into smaller services.
Well the idea here is to
make the services fine
grained and make
the communication
protocols between these
services lightweight and simple.
And also, many of
the enterprises
are making the assumption
that the trust is established
between the services without
actually enforcing policies.
So the idea of a good
microservices architecture
is to increase
product velocity, you
want to release your features
as often as possible,
manage complexity
of the code, and you
want to admit heterogeneity.
Each developer has
their own tool search.
Maybe they like [? scanner ?]
some teams might like Java,
some teams might like Darknet.
You want to admit that.
And then you want to
apply security policies.
Very, very important.
You want to enable that
trust, so enterprise security
policies.
And then at the
same time, you want
to empower your developers to
be as quick as possible and as
independent as possible.
So this is how an enterprise
services can look like.
You have multiple services.
They are all
communicating with APIs.
And by default, APIs becomes
a communication contract
between services.
Every system that
can receive requests
has some kind of an EPA.
They can be RESTful,
they, can be SOAP,
or maybe thousand different
ways of doing APIs.
Or maybe they're using
GraphQL, gipc, YAML.
So there's a mesh of services
within the enterprise.
And then when a consumer,
from outside or from inside
calls an API, they orchestrate
the calls within the mesh
and get back with the response.
So we are getting into
some kind of a mesh here.
Let's see how to enable this.
Let's dig in deep a little bit.
We have service A, we
have service B. Now
these are microservices.
How do you enable
communications with them?
The best way is to
have mutual dealers.
Ideally, you want
to have certificates
for each of the
services, and once you
have unique certificates, you
can enable those certificates
on the other services.
And you also want to
introduce centrally described
communication policies
like lead tries, timeout,
circuit breakers if a
call is taking too long.
You want to enable routing
so that if the services are
located in different
regions, different teams
to enable the routing
in efficient way.
And on top of it,
you want to enable
[INAUDIBLE] the
authentication authorization.
Maybe not every
service is consumable
by the other service,
so to be informed,
you authorize those services.
When this is happening, you want
to collect analytics and also
monitor the services.
You want to know at
any point in time
whether the service
is up or down.
And at the same time,
you want to enable
some kind of telemetry so that
you know who is consuming what
at any point in time.
So we need a sort of a
support system to enable this.
Let us see how to
make this happen.
So let's delegate
all this complexity
of this communication protocols
to a standalone, something
called Envoy.
Envoy is a high
performance plug-able proxy
providing inflow networking
and observability for increased
service communication.
So Envoy was built on
learning from [INAUDIBLE]..
Envoy is very popular
and widely used.
And it's very widely
used inside Google also.
Envoy uses what we
called a sidecar pattern.
And the sidecar
pattern is better
than embedding
different [INAUDIBLE]
and making it a big monolith.
So with this
pattern, it's easier
to support services implemented
in multiple languages.
And also, you can upgrade
the proxies independent
of other services.
So this is where a good
control plane will help
you to manage your services.
So me as a data scientist,
at this point I'm thinking
is this challenging
or is this simple?
Now a model has become part
of a mesh architecture.
It's no more a silo.
So models are part of a big
piece in the enterprise.
So let's start digging deep now.
We want to introduce the control
plane, which is a service mesh.
What does a service
mesh help us to do?
It'll help us to connect
between the services, the flow
of traffic between
services, it'll
help to secure the endpoint
between the services
and encrypted communication,
very, very important.
And you want to control this
by applying security policies.
And then you want to
observe and collect
metrics for monitoring
and analytics purpose.
Let's dig in a little bit deep.
This is where Istio
comes into play.
Istio starts with the Envoy
proxy as a sidecar pattern,
and then access our top policies
to help and manage [INAUDIBLE]
the distributed set of proxies.
As you can see in this picture
here, you have the Envoy,
you have the control
plane, and then
we'll also introduce what is
called as API management here.
So let us talk to this.
So how an API management
layer will help you.
You have the services.
And you want to enable them,
both for internal consumption
and your external consumption.
And let's start with
an example, and I'll
explain to you on how
the API management
layer will help you to do this.
So let's take this example
where we have a legacy app,
and you have a monolith app,
and you have your consumption
layer.
All these modeled apps,
you have the legacy apps,
and then most of the
enterprises have an API gateway.
In this case, Apigee API
gateway is a GCP offering
to provide you a full-fledged
size offering to manage APIs.
Most of the enterprises
enable their services
through the API layer.
API layer kind of
acts as a switch
to switch between different
services in the backend.
And then you have
your internal apps.
Most places, internal
apps are directly
going against the services.
There's not much
of API management
going on in that layer.
Now let us go through this
journey of breaking down
a monolith into microservices.
So let's take the Monolith
2 and break it down
into smaller services.
At the same time, you're
updating the internal app
to consume your microservices
as well as the monolith.
And at the same time,
you're updating your gateway
to also use their services,
the new microservices.
And in the process,
what you're doing
is you're introducing
new capabilities
by adding more microservices,
and also you're
introducing ML pipelines
using Cloud ML platform.
This is where you're adding
more capabilities where
your internal apps
are being updated
to consume these
new capabilities,
and at the same
time, you're keeping
it transparent for your
external consumption
to use in your capabilities.
So this is, as you
can see in this,
the onset of proliferation
of different services.
So this is a problem.
Probably a good problem to have.
Let us see how we
can simplify this.
So this is where
Istio control plane
will help you to build a
service mesh architecture.
In this diagram, you'll
see the service mesh
is kind of helping to
manage the communication
between the services.
You also see the legacy systems
using the legacy service
as being exposed to the gateway
to the third-party system.
And also the internal
apps are using the legacy,
but at the same time,
the internal apps
are now being consuming
the services from the mesh.
And in fact, the
gateway is acting
like a nice little
switch to switch
between the legacy and the new
layer of mesh architecture.
You can also see what is
called as Apigee adapter,
and this is where you
get the API policies.
Now what does the
adapter help you to do?
It'll help you to centrally
govern or manage APIs.
It enables API
publishing, visibility
of the APIs by publishing
them into portals,
enables governance,
good governance,
by applying your best practices,
and it collects the analytics.
Specifically from a
security perspective,
the adapter will help you
enforce in the Envoy things
like verifying the OAuth
token on the API keys,
checking if there's
enough authorization
to consume the services, and
other things like a quota.
If you have some kind of
a quota on the service,
it'll enforce that.
If you have rate limiting,
If you have text
protection to validate
any text coming on the
APIs, it'll enforce that.
So basically
adapter's helping you
to do these kind of
security policies.
And Istio service
mesh is helping
you to enable the communication
between the services.
This is kind of a
clean model and where
the suppression of concerns
is very clearly maintained.
So let us understand
how this is happening.
So Envoy supports a
long list of filters,
and these filters are written
in C++ and compiled into Envoy
itself.
Apigee adapter uses
one specific filter
called external authorization
external outfitter, which
is designed to allow Envoy
to delegate authorization
decisions to an external system.
This is where Apigee is
registered and gets a control.
So let's see how the
traffic flow happens here.
So when API call
comes into Envoy,
the Envoy gives the
control to Apigee adapter.
In this case, we call it
as Apigee's remote service.
Apigee's remote
service will go back
with either a yay or a nay.
So what it will do is
it'll enforce the policies
that the API
publisher has designed
for this particular consumption.
So it can be OAuth, it can
be quotas-type production,
rate limiting.
Any policies they have,
it's enforced here.
If that app responds
back with a yay,
then it'll go back to
your backend service,
and then the call as
passes in your backend.
If it is a nay, then an error
is sent back to your consumer.
So Apigee's remote service is
acting as a policy decision
point.
And it is to Envoy to unload
the API consumption [INAUDIBLE]..
Now how does this work in a
very high-performance system?
How can you get those
hundreds and thousands of TPLs
in API call?
So first the communication
between the proxy
and the Apigee's
remote services gRPC.
So this is very good for
speed and efficiency.
And then, the Apigee's remote
service talks to its management
plane and downloads
anything that
is required to make
their decision, which
includes the policies,
keys, [INAUDIBLE],,
anything that required.
It's all cached inside
the remote servers.
So this is how the
Apigee's remote service
is built for a high-performing
support system.
So let's try to bring
everything together.
So why use API management
in your service mesh?
So you don't want any of the
services to be in a siloed.
Whether it is your Cloud
AI prediction models,
whether it can be
a microservice,
it can be anything.
It needs to be discovered.
And how do you discover them?
So with Apigee, you can
have a portal where you
can publish all your services.
And this portal can
be designed in a way
that the consumers can
act in a self-service way.
There is no more
whitelisting the firewalls,
whitelisting your APIs.
Someone can come and say I
need access to certain APIs,
and then your API producer
can get a request,
and then they can
upload the request.
And then you can
modernize your services.
All the stuff on the legacy,
your old monolith applications,
everything can be hidden
by a nice little APIs using
REST or any standards
that you use
and expose them in a good way.
And then no more exchanging
those PDF files or Word files.
You can have nice documentation
wherein you view the required
technical aspects for
the API, and the consumer
can comment and try those
APIs before you want
to use it in the application.
And then you can have
reports on the services.
This is very, very critical.
At any point, you should be
able to answer the questions
like who are my top
five consumers, or what
are my SLAs that
were satisfied today,
or what was my performance,
what kind of products
are used from a business aspect?
So you should be able to answer
these kind of questions using
the analytics that you covered.
And in a large
enterprise, governance
becomes very, very important.
You want some kind of
best practices enforced
across the teams,
and this is critical.
You can enforce things like
CI/CD, linting, code standards,
all these kinds of things
across the enterprise.
You can enable and enforce them.
Now once you have the APIs,
it's very, very critical
you monitor them.
At any point, you should
know which service is up,
which service is slowing down
before your consumers tell you,
which is very, very important.
And then once you have this
nice little system working,
you want to start
making money off of it.
You want to accept a
credit card and start
charging your consumers.
And this is where the
monetization module in Apigee
comes into picture.
You can plug it in and
define your policies
on how to monetize the APIs.
Maybe not all APIs
need to be monetized.
Maybe you pick a few business
APIs which are critical.
You only monetize a
certain set of APIs.
These kind of behaviors
can be [INAUDIBLE]
and with a good API
management layer.
So we have a solution page
which ties up all of this.
And you should be able to
try it, make a prediction
model in the Cloud AI platform,
and then expose that AI
model using the Apigee
engine, and then
send it to your consumers.
So all this in a
frictionless way.
We have a solution page
explaining all of this.
I would say the biggest
takeaway for you
in this session will
be once you have this
modeled, how can your
model the other services,
how can you make your
consumption of these services
seamless, frictionless.
You want the consumption
to be the easiest of all
so that your services are
actually consumed a lot faster,
giving the benefit
to the enterprise.
The impact is a lot
more faster if you
remove those kinds of friction.
So the biggest
takeaway will be how
do you bring in your services
in a way that can be consumed
without any friction?
Looking ahead, we
have a solution page
where you can try this
sample example where you can
try the AI platform and Apigee.
We have step-by-step
instructions.
You can get a free
trial account.
You get almost all the
features in a SaaS platform.
You can try it out.
We have a very good community.
A lot of questions have
been asked and answered.
If you have more questions,
feel free to ask that.
One of us will answer that.
And if you need to reach one
of us for more discussion,
feel free to reach out
to either Kaz or me,
and we'll be happy
to help you out.
If you need more
information, contact us.
One of us will get
in touch with you.
Thank you again for joining us.
Have a great day.